ROBBIE: Let's check it.
How you doing?
DAN: Alright.
ROBBIE: You Dan or Rob?
DAN: I'm Dan.
ROBBIE: How you doing?
FRANK: Dan, how you doing?
I'm Frank.
DAN: Hey, Frank.
FRANK: Is your
brother Rob around?
DAN: Yeah, he's over
in the building.
FRANK: Can we go see him?
DAN: Yeah.
FRANK: Wow, it's a big place.
DAN: Rob!
ROBBIE: Rob.
FRANK: How you doing, my friend?
ROBBIE: Nice to see you.
Rob Wolfe.
FRANK: So you've been talking
to Danielle a little bit?
ROB: Danny talked to her
and I'm disappointed.
Why'd they send
you twinkies for?
I thought she was coming.
ROBBIE: Hey,
aren't I as good-looking?
ROB: No.
This is chronic disappointment.
FRANK: I'll tell you what we
did bring, Benjamin Franklins.
ROB: Well, I tell ya,
we're a high-volume,
low-quality place here.
FRANK: Oh, yeah?
ROB: We got a lot of stuff,
so...
FRANK: Buy high, sell low?
ROBBIE: Wow.
ROB: No, just
buy low, sell low.
ROB: In cow poop...
there might be a
little piece of corn.
ROB: That's a
neat wall-hanger.
ROB: We pick the corn
out of the cow poop.
FRANK: Hey, Rob.
What about this lovely item?
ROB: Yeah.
FRANK: So this
would be a display.
It would just sit up,
have a little peg,
it'd sit up on the top here.
Something you'd sell?
ROB: It's definitely for sale,
Frank, if it's something you...
FRANK: $200.
ROB: You know what, it's
gonna be a long day, Frank.
I'm gonna let you have it,
'cause I'm afraid you're
gonna run out of money.
FRANK: So, 200?
ROB: Yeah, 200, but...
FRANK: Alright.
ROB: But don't stop now.
ROBBIE: I gotta hand it
to Rob and Dan--
this stuff came to them as trash
and they saw it as treasure.
FRANK: So, Rob, what's up
with this Texaco sign here?
ROB: Frank,
I don't think it's...
It's not a legitimate...
Uh, I think someone painted it,
is what I'm saying.
FRANK: Oh, you think
it's a fantasy piece?
ROB: Yeah, I think somebody
painted it and made it--
they did a nice job.
The best part is,
it could be yours.
FRANK: That's the best part?
ROB: That's the best part.
FRANK: Since it's not
a real sign, but it is--
does display well...
ROB: Yeah.
FRANK: $150.
ROB: I think $200
would be better.
FRANK: $200?
If it was real,
I'd give you 300.
ROB: How about the 175?
I know that's
where you're going.
FRANK: You've been
around the block a while.
ROB: No, no, I haven't.
FRANK: Let's do it.
ROB: This is
the very first time.
FRANK: Oh, yeah.
ROB: Most people have a plan.
They work, and they invest,
and they're going to retire.
And I think deep down
maybe that was the plan,
but...
DAN: Yeah.
ROB: ...part of that plan,
to execute it properly,
is you gotta sell.
FRANK: Oh, thanks.
ROB: There you go.
There's your baby.
ROBBIE: Man, I'll tell you what,
it's been a great day!
ROB: And you know, I'll tell
you something about having crap,
when someone like, you know, Rob
and Frank come and look at it,
it gives you a little,
a little...
DAN: A little validation.
ROB: A little validation,
a little 'atta-boy.
"Oh, man, they liked it too!
Well, maybe I'm not crazy!"
FRANK: We could
come back in a week,
and still not see stuff
that we didn't see today.
ROB: You think they had fun?
I mean, they saw a lot of stuff
and they seemed
to appreciate it.
FRANK: See you later, guys!
Take care now!
ROBBIE: Thanks!
DAN: Later.
[honks horn]